hello there I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Dan
sagres so a lot of people been asking us
to check out a game for it's based on a
movie actually the Mad Max 2015 video
game I like the Mad Max original trilogy
of course I haven't seen the new one yet
but I'm really stoked to see that one I
hope this game is as crazy as the movies
are I always approach games made from
movies with a light optimism about it
because generally generally they suck
but yeah there's a few really good ones
this one is like highly requested so
maybe they actually know what they're
doing with this one good
all right your name max my name is Max
and Mad Max you begin with nothing
your car your family your life
everything has been taken from you
now all that's left is your will to
survive the first thing you must do is
build a new car pair Steelers magnum
opus this is your magnum opus acquiring
necessary gear throughout your journey
allows you to upgrade your vehicle build
and customize Unitas
just the way you want
in addition you will need to equip
yourself with armor and weapons in order
to stand a chance against your enemies
as you progress you will also need to
upgrade your gear and abilities to
survive against the brutal forces of a
wasteland griffa can help help you event
you down to a ad and go yourself and lay
bare your true promise
while ammunition can be exceedingly
Spears there are plenty of other weapons
at your disposal that can prove to be
just as deadly
oh the wasteland is also filled with
valuable scrap that lets you forge new
weapons upgrade armor and make powerful
improvements to the magnum opus
providing you with the strength to
continue fighting effectively
those with resources rule the wasteland
and scrotus and his war voids are the
ones in control
Wow you're merciless lethal and
relentless in their thirst for blood
down here if you want to increase your
chances of survival you can't let
anything stand in your way
you must be ruthless the wasteland is no
place for a conscience
as you travel through the sprawling open
world you will meet those that have
carved out a meager existence in the
wasteland making alliances with these
inhabitants will help them and their
strongholds thrive and provide you with
additional aid along your journey and
you need powder black deadly and smoky
and that's where I come in
listen you go get me this and you're set
for a mo for life
you must take on the forces that rule
the wasteland and endure the
unpredictable elements of nature
there are dangerous faction that roam
the roads dwell underground and rule the
night they will try to steal what little
you have left
but you still have what it takes defeat
your enemies and reclaim the light they
store
will suffice
because you are max
Wow
I literally have chills holy like goose
oh do look nipple erect nipple right
there you see that people that's how
much chills I have huh dude so much to
talk about
from that one trailer out first off Dan
doesn't seem as impressed with me I'm
not why what's wrong hi and compared
something early on when I started doing
these videos with you to call a duty I
realized that's not that's not the right
way to approach a game to like compare
to ugly like say oh it looks like this
oh it looks like this it looks like that
it's just what I'm watching that all I'm
like oh you mean like that game oh you
mean like this game oh you mean like
that game I don't know it just doesn't
see like there's nothing that's like
grabbing me and say like this is a
completely unique experience that you've
never tried before
okay okay I'll give you that yeah like
there's elements of like uncharted in
there it looks like undertale Otto it
looks like even like a lot of stuff
sneaky mission man Arkham Asylum but you
gotta give the benefit of doubt as far
as movie adaptation into video games go
true that looks pretty drugged and
amazing true true
because when you watch the Mad Max whole
universe you know I'm glad they made
this an open-world adventure game mhm
because it is about that it's about Mad
Max is about the world the
post-apocalyptic world and they're
including all the elements we like from
those movies they got some really cool
car stuff down you could build your own
car it's not like you just Jack someone
else's vehicle that part is cool I'm
interested to see the different things
they could do like the game play with
the cars looks awesome - I like how its
violent when you're doing this fighting
- yeah like it's not like just some
pretty martial arts moves like he's like
[ __ ] them oh yeah there's like
braking arms stabbing them and stuff
it's brutal its violent it looks
inspired by Mad Max but it doesn't look
like one of those carbon copies where
they just turn it into a video game I
like how it ties with nature like yes a
lot of other video games have done very
similar things but I think it's really
cool that they're giving us a
Ariane's to live through this movie
world through a videogame
yeah and I mean I'll give it this the
game looks [ __ ] gorgeous oh it does
yeah like for a wasteland environment it
looks very unique very pretty
I've heard trailers before saying like
you could build your own car you'd be
doing combat you'll be finding weapons
and you'll be [ __ ] like saving so
like these things and then like it's
like oh my god I can do this this and
this and then you get to it and it's
just very very like basic like they try
to do so many things that they didn't do
one thing right now however with that
said I won't give it the benefit of the
doubt because I don't know how it's like
until I play it it is just a trailer
after all it is just a trailer like if I
miss the days of demos that was just not
happen anymore I'd love to try the game
now because it looks fun but I also see
it as a game that's probably not gonna
pull me in like some other games I
played I just want to be max I'm
assuming if anyone's a Mad Max fan
they're gonna [ __ ] love yeah yeah and
I think the movies only going to help oh
yeah push sales yeah yeah well anyway
guys oh I have a rating system now
definitely want to play it mm-hmm wait
to play a dance not even bother with it
I am definitely going to play it
thumbnail Dan
I'll play it at the Best Buy anyway guys
thanks for letting us know that was out
I really dug it if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects Dan over here has a gaming
channel check that [ __ ] out if I piss
you off yeah I get my opinion of course
you can
let's dis me my liked nope you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
no [ __ ] I just want to do product
placement product placement you can
follow me and we could talk we can have
a nice debate over the merits of life
yeah whatever whatever that Andrew
Heights DeMarco Urich in Watson hi I am
a fellow youtuber i watch your channel
more than my parents would want me to
haha I can't get anything done because
you guys are so entertaining that's good
to know we have contributed to your
laziness but my name is DeMarco Watson
but can you shout out my youtube channel
de Marco Polo de Marco Polo is an
awesome channel that consists of a man
who blurs out images of him having sex
with animals I'm not going to show a
picture of him because he sounds like he
still lives with his parents
but I'm telling you right now bestiality
de Marco it's dangerous territory really
likely to get infections I'm pretty sure
that's that's exactly what he does how
would you know because it's his de Marco
Polo I've seen the channel do you review
polo shirts no he [ __ ] animals and I
drag off to those videos